-Hi, welcome.
I'm John Huth.
I'm with the Physics Department
and also the Radcliffe
Institute for Advanced Study.
So let me just say a few
words about Radcliffe.
We have multiple programs here.
And its mission is explicitly
to be cross-disciplinary,
multidisciplinary,
which distinguishes it
from other institutes
for advanced study.
And to be engaged
in this institution
has been just amazing
for me because I've
learned all sorts of
things that I wouldn't
thought I would have learned.
I'm a particle
physicist by trade
and I get into all sorts
of topics like the oceans,
for example.
We have many programs that
includes a fellowship program,
where people can come and spend
a year here with scientists,
playwrights, people in
the humanities, artists.
There's a Schlesinger
Library and it's
dedicated to the history
of women in America.
I'm a member of the
Ventures faculty, which
runs our number of programs,
including exploratory seminars,
which are meant to be
interdisciplinary, workshops
and science symposium.
This coming year our
science symposium
is on the oceans, looking
at various aspects
various aspects of oceans like
the early life in the oceans,
where it came from, life in
hydrothermal vents for example,
and also the outsized role that
oceans play in our climate.
We also will be having
a series of lectures.
The ocean's symposium
is on October 28.
Our kickoff lecture
is Monday October 24
by Kerry Emanuel, who is a
climatologist, meteorologist
expert from MIT, who came up
with the concept of hyper cane
which is a hurricane that
will occur if the sea
temperatures rise
about 15 degrees C,
and has predicted that
with the warming oceans
the frequency of
hurricanes will decrease
but their intensity will
increase tremendously.
So that's on October 24.
What we have here
is our kickoff event
of a series that is
called Next In Science.
And the idea is that we're
going to bring early career
scientists to talk about their
work to a general audience.
And I guess this is
in part motivated
by what I've observed that a lot
of the interesting new science
is happening at the intersection
between disciplines,
always has.
And often times the
way universities
are set up with
departments, the departments
can sometimes be
somewhat stovepiped
and miss opportunities.
And in fact, a lot
of young scientists
tend to gravitate
to work that tends
to be at the boundaries
of disciplines.
And so in a way by exposing
Harvard and the public
to their work, we are
trying to educate ourselves
about new areas, emerging
areas in the sciences
in addition to
getting some exposure
to the young scientists.
Just as an example,
in my own discipline,
particle physics, which
is I would say rather
mature at this point, it
had its start in study--
well one of the starts in
experimental particle physics
was in the study of clouds.
There are various theories
about how clouds formed.
One of them was accretion
around dust particles.
Another was around charged
particles in the atmosphere.
And cloud chambers
were invented basically
to try to make clouds.
And as an accidental
result, people
were able to find charged
particles using clouds.
And so there you have sort
of a funny, accidental,
cross-disciplinary work
that absolutely innovated
the field of particle physics.
So as I said, we focus on
early career scientists
and we try to have a theme.
Keeping in the theme
with the oceans,
we decided to gather together
four outstanding scientists,
early career scientists, to talk
about their work in the oceans.
And since I helped
organize this I
had I guess the privilege
of picking the topics
that I found the most
interesting and the speakers
that I found the
most interesting.
Even though you
might not realize it,
we did a little homework
before we asked you to come.
So, the format is, we'll have to
approximately 30 minute talks.
Hold your questions for them.
We'll then go to questions from
the audience, take a break,
and then come back
for two more talks.
And I think they'll
be fascinating,
at least I'm going to be on
the edge of my seat listening.
So the first speaker today
is Dr. Rachel Gittman,
who is from the Marine
Science Center at Northeastern
University and got her doctorate
at the University of North
Carolina at Chapel
Hill and is going
to talk on the
subject of shorelines.
I'll just say some words
about why I get interested
in these things, but since
I'm not a sea kayaker,
I spend a lot of
time on the coast
and I'm always looking
at the dynamics of what's
happening when shorelines
and why the sands going away
here and going over
there, and also pondering
why some large jetty
is cracking apart
and the sand is all disappearing
behind that jetty which
was supposed to hold back
the sand from erosion.
And so Rachel is going
to talk about this topic.
And the title of her talk
is Living Shorelines: Are We
Designing Functional Sustainable
and Resilient Coasts.
Rachel.
[APPLAUSE]
-Thank you for that
introduction and thank you
all for coming today.
So just a little
background since this
is kind of a diverse group.
I'm an ecologist by training.
I'm going to start kind
of with some ecology
and because this is an
interdisciplinary talk, kind
of move into a tiny, tiny
bit of the engineering side
and then into some
social science.
So our coastlines are incredibly
diverse, not just in the US,
but globally.
They can encompass
your ocean shorelines,
like your sand beaches,
your rocky shores, and also
your sheltered coastlines,
like your coastal tidal marshes
and also mangroves.
And they're incredibly
valuable systems.
So they encompass only
about 4% of the actual land
on the earth, but
they're extremely
valuable in terms of their goods
and services that they provide.
So there's been several studies
looking at ecosystem services
provided by our coastlines.
And they just come
out disproportionately
above a lot of our other
terrestrial ecosystems.
And one of these services
that I think about a lot
is this service of providing
habitat to marine organisms.
And so our coastal habitats such
as mangroves, marshes, and also
our open coast shore alliance,
they really serve as a nursery.
They serve as a habitat
through all life history
stages for lots of
marine organisms.
And most importantly
for people they
serve as habitat for a lot of
commercially and recreationally
valuable fish.
So you might recognize, if
you're from New England, cod.
Cod actually spend some
of their life history
in shallow, rocky,
cobble bottom habitats,
also sea grass habitats.
This fish is actually really
famous in North Carolina,
the red drum or red fish
also in the Gulf Coast.
Spends a lot of its
early life history
in sea grasses and marshes.
And these are some juveniles of
speckled trout, Black Sea bass,
and also snapper that are
often pulled right out
of some really tidally shallow
salt marshes in North Carolina.
And then I throw this one in.
This is actually
in the Galapagos.
These are Bacalao or grouper.
They actually, in
their early life
history stages are
using mangrove habitats
in the Galapagos.
So, globally, these habitats,
these near shore habitats,
are incredibly important
for our fisheries.
They're highly productive.
In the US alone,
roughly 75% of all
of the fishes that are
commercially or recreationally
harvested depend on estuarine
or these shallow, near shore
habitats at one or more of
their life history stages.
So these habitats are
incredibly valuable
but they're also imperiled.
So we've seen unprecedented
degradation and loss
of our vegetated near
coastal habitats.
From a quarter to
nearly half of these
habitats globally
have been lost.
And we've even
seen greater losses
with some of our reefs, our
shellfish reefs, like oysters
and also our coral reefs.
And there's a number of
factors at play here.
So you'll hear about climate
change in the talks today,
but you also need
to think about all
of the other human factors
that are at play here.
And coastal development is
one that I think about a lot
because we are right
along the coast.
And I'd like to put this slide
up because this is actually,
this is Dubai.
So not only are they
developing their coastline,
they're actually
creating coastline
to then provide
waterfront development.
So they're dredging up the
sand and building islands
so that people can have
waterfront property.
So you can imagine that that
has pretty dire ecological, also
physical consequences for those
coastlines and those habitats.
And so we might say,
well, that's Dubai.
We don't do that
kind of thing here.
But that's actually not true.
This is actually a shot I
took flying into Logan on one
of my trips back up to Boston.
And you know, it's a pretty
densely populated coastline,
right?
So New England's got a lot of
people and we love our coast.
Everyone loves Cape Cod.
And these resources
are valued just
for recreation and tourism.
But obviously having
this many people
living along the coastline can
have some real consequences
for those ecosystems.
Now in a natural setting
devoid of people,
there are a fair number
of stressors that occur
for these coastal ecosystems.
This is actually a salt
marsh in North Carolina.
And this is a core sound.
So it's a pretty large sound.
It's shallow, but when
you get the wind blowing
from the right direction,
the fetch is very large
or the distance across
the sound is fairly large.
And you'll get a significant
amount of wave energy
hitting these coastal
habitats these marshes.
And so they erode over time and
they essentially roll back up
into the uplands as they erode.
And so this is a
dynamic, natural process.
Shorelines erode.
They move around.
As John was kind of alluding
to, sand is not static.
It's not staying in one place.
And so this is not
really something
we're concerned
about as scientists,
that we have erosion
or that this marsh is
going to flood at high tide.
These are all natural processes.
It's really when we have kind of
the loss of these habitats then
tied to human infrastructure
that people really
start to worry about it.
Because these systems are
going to persist through time,
geologic history has shown us.
We still have salt marshes.
We're going to continue
to have salt marshes.
But it's really when
we as humans, come in
and we draw a line in
the sand, and we say,
this is my waterfront property.
I want it to stay
here for my lifetime
that we start to see an issue.
And this is a picture I took.
This is in Dauphin
Island, Alabama.
So people have decided that
they want to live right
on the water, and over time, the
ocean has eroded away the sand
and their house is going
to fall in the water.
And this is actually
not inhabited anymore.
There's caution tape,
they're not allowed to go in.
And this is up and
down the coast.
It's not just from
hurricanes, it's
actually just poor
zoning and poor planning.
And this is a picture from
New Bern, North Carolina.
So this is actually last year.
They had a tremendous amount
of rainfall in the fall.
And then you also tend to have
these really high, high tides
or king tides in the fall.
And so this is just a normal day
where the high tide has come in
and completely flooded
the downtown area.
And this is a pretty
regular occurrence now.
And this happens in Boston.
It happens in cities
throughout the East Coast.
So that's why we have to
kind of take a step back
and say, OK, we're doing
all of this development.
We want to live along the coast.
Over a third of the
global population
lives within 100
kilometers of the coast,
and people are moving
towards the coasts.
So these numbers are
going to increase.
What can we really do or how
can we live along the coast
and also protect
this infrastructure?
Well, historically, what we
have done at least, the last,
I would say 100,
150 years in the US,
has been to harden
the shoreline.
So the US Army
Corps of Engineers,
they have done tremendous
things in our country
in terms of redirecting
rivers and also
hardening our shorelines.
They build these sea walls.
They'll build
groins and jetties,
the big shore perpendicular
rock structures
you often see at inlets.
The idea is that you'll
engineer your way out
of this problem of
coastal hazards,
this problem the erosion,
or this problem of flooding.
And so that's really what
we've done in the past.
We built sea walls.
This is one actually,
at Linshore Drive,
so up near Swanstat,
if you know that area.
This is a riprap or revetment.
So it's just essentially rock
piled up along the shore.
And then this is actually a
break water, so again rock
and in this case, it's
actually morrel actually placed
seaward of a tidal salt marsh.
And so, I'll actually talk
about these structures
in the terms of calling them a
living shoreline a little bit
later in the talk.
But these are the two
more traditional types
of hardening that I really
focus on with my work.
So in starting to think about
this issue, when I was starting
graduate school I
wanted to do work
on understanding
the ecology or what
was happening when you
harden the shoreline
to these near shore habitats.
The first question I
really had was well,
how much does this happen?
How much hardening
do we actually
have in the United States?
I thought this would be an easy
number that I could look up.
It turns out we had no idea.
So after scouring
a lot of data sets,
I actually came
across a NOAA data
set that was used for oil spill
response where they classified
different shoreline types, but
they had never actually thought
to do the math and to actually
figure out how much of this
was actually
artificial shoreline.
And so I did that
essentially for them.
And so what I
found is that well,
if we just take a
subset of this shoreline
and you look just
at New England,
I figured out that about 10% of
the shoreline from Connecticut
to Maine is hardened.
And so this is a map
showing the warm colors
being a higher percentage
of the shoreline that's
actually hardened relative to
the total amount of shoreline.
Cool colors being less.
It shouldn't really
be any surprise
that the Boston area is
fairly highly hardened.
And if you look at the US
as a whole, it's roughly 14%
of the US coastline.
This is about 22,000 kilometers,
roughly 14,000 miles.
And I had a colleague actually
say that it's essentially
like saying, you could
take one in six steps
and you could encounter
a hardened shoreline,
which I thought was a kind of
neat way to think about it.
So 14% might not seem
like a whole lot,
but when you think about how
much coast we actually have,
it's a pretty
substantial number.
And it's likely to increase,
given the number of people
that are moving to the coasts.
So I did a series
of analyzes to kind
of figure out what's most
correlated with shoreline
hardening.
And it's no surprise
that you know,
housing density is
positively correlated
with shoreline hardening.
The more people you have,
the more houses you have,
the more hardening you have.
So if you look at predictions
for population growth,
what we see is that really
it's the South Atlantic
and the Gulf Coast
are predicted to see
the largest increases
in population
in the coming decades.
So we expect these
areas to be probably
the ones that are going to
get hardened the quickest
unless coastal management
policies change.
The Northeast, we have seen
kind of natural rocky shores,
and a lot of the area has
actually already been developed
and are already hardened.
So we're probably reaching some
kind of plateau in hardening.
But it's these areas that
are relatively undeveloped
now that we really
need to be focused on.
So why do we care if we're
hardening the shoreline?
It's essentially
just a different type
of shoreline right?
We're using hard materials.
What does it do in terms of
providing functional habitat?
Is it equivalent to having
a marsh shoreline or just
a natural rocky shoreline?
Is it equivalent in terms
of providing fish habitat?
So this is a question
that I really wanted
to ask kind of the last year.
And so what I did was I
did a meta-analysis of all
the peer-reviewed studies on
shoreline hardening in terms
of measuring the biodiversity
of those shoreline types,
so the number and
types of organisms,
and the overall
abundance of organisms
on hardened shorelines
and then compared them
to natural shorelines.
So those are all the
studies that have ever
been published globally.
So it's not just US studies
but also a lot of work
out of Europe and
also Australia.
And the three types of
shorelines I focused on were
are the ones that are
most commonly used.
So sea walls and bulkheads,
these are vertical walls.
They're made of
concrete, wood, vinyl,
depends on where you are.
Riprap or revetment, so it's
some type of rock or concrete
piled along the shore.
And then these breakwaters
that can sometimes
include some kind of
marsh, but sometimes not.
And so I categorize them
into these three groups
and then I took all of
the data from the studies
to determine what the overall
effect was on biodiversity,
and also just the total
number of organisms
occupying these habitat.
And so this is just a
table showing the number
of studies and the
responses by category
for biodiversity and abundance.
And this is just to
give you a visual
of the types of organisms
we're talking about.
So I had five different kind
of categories of organisms.
So flora are these
plants, so effect
on the actual marsh or sea
grass or mangrove habitat.
Epibiota is anything that's
growing directly on the shores.
So you might have or oysters,
ribbed mussels, barnacles,
tuna kits, anything
that's actually
attaching to the surface.
Shore birds, so any kind of
marine or shore-based bird,
sea gulls, plovers, anything
dependent on shore habitat.
Nekton is really mobile
fishes and crustations, so
your decapods, your
crabs also any fish that
might be using the habitat.
And then benthic
infauna is a whole suite
of organisms actually
living in the sediments.
So it can be bivalves,
gastropods, also polychaetes.
So I'm going to show
you a series of graphs
here on biodiversity and
abundance of effects.
And so all you really
need to understand
here is that this is a
measure of effect size.
And the more
negative on this axis
means the larger
the negative effect
on biodiversity and
abundance, so the worse it
is for biodiversity
and abundance.
And this is for seawalls first,
riprap, and then breakwaters.
And I'm just going to
highlight seawalls here.
Because there are
this is the group
of structures that had a
significant negative effect
on biodiversity and abundance.
So across all of
the studies that I
was able to compile
data from, we
had a consistent negative
effect of this type of structure
relative to a natural shoreline
on the overall ecosystem
biodiversity and abundance.
And if this kind of
log response ratio
is not that intuitive to you,
another way to think about it
is a difference, a percent
difference in the biodiversity
in abundance.
And so you're essentially
talking about a little
over a 25% loss in biodiversity,
and also around a 35% to 40%
loss in abundance.
This is biodiversity
and this is abundance
when you have a sea wall
instead of a natural shoreline
like a rocky shoreline
or a marsh shoreline.
The other two structure
types, we did not
have a significant effect.
They were not different
from natural shoreline.
But I will say that this is
actually likely due to there
being fewer number of studies.
So we didn't have enough studies
to really definitively say
whether or not they
are different or not.
And so I'm hoping we'll
see more work come out
in the coming years.
So the jury's still kind
of out on these other types
of shorelines.
So just to give you an
idea of who's affected,
so I mentioned the
benthic infauna.
And I just list a couple
of examples studies,
but it's really either
polychaete anthropods and also
these filter-feeding
bivalves, clams, mussels,
that kind of thing that
are living in the sediment.
Shore birds are negatively
affected by sea walls,
likely because when you
have a seawall in place,
the beach often goes away
in front of the seawall.
And these shore birds depend on
that shallow, inner tidal zone,
that swash zone to feed
on benthic invertebrates.
And then Nekton or your fish and
crustaceans are also affected.
And these are largely
organisms that
are utilizing salt marsh habitat
and also seagrass habitat.
So when you lose that marsh
habitat or you replace it
with a bulkhead or a
seawall, you're often
losing these marsh
residents like mummichogs,
or the little marsh
killifish, or panaeid shrimp,
so shrimp that we like to
eat, and also blue crabs
from the Southeast,
so organisms that
are very dependent on that
vegetative structured habitat
tend to suffer when you
bulkhead a shoreline.
But it's not just that snapshot
biodiversity and abundance
that we care about.
We're also concerned about
the long term consequences
of armoring the shoreline.
So typically, when
you have a-- this
is a typical shoreline
for the Southeast
or maybe for the tidal creeks
and the marshes up in New
England, you're going to have
a shallow sloping tidal marsh,
a shallow water refuge, and
then maybe some sea grass
here, occupied by lots of
juvenile fish and crustaceans,
shore birds, and whatnot.
When you put a
bulkhead in place,
even though it's
permit to actually
be landward of this
marsh, we're facing things
like sea level rise
and also just increased
severity of storm events.
And so over time,
you essentially
lose that marsh because
this bulkhead is not
absorbing energy.
It's essentially
reflecting it back.
And so you get a deepening of
that intertidal environment
through scour of the sediment.
And engineers have known
this for a long time.
They actually typically pile
of rock in front of bulkheads
now to prevent that tow scour.
So this is not new
knowledge, but it's
something that's been really
hard to document in terms
of loss of marsh and sea grass
and other vegetative habitats,
which is why it's actually
still permitted in the US,
even though wetlands
are federally protected.
So this is something that
a lot of colleagues of mine
are trying to document
now, because it
happens over decade scales, as
opposed to just the one or two
years that you typically get
funding for a research project.
And so right now I think we
have about 10 to 15 years
worth of data on a
set of shorelines,
and I'm hoping that we'll
be able to publish something
in the near future to kind
of document this loss.
But the really important
part about understanding
this process is this is
happening below the high water
line, which is really typically
public trust resources.
So these are areas that are
owned by the general public,
and not by the
private property owner
or developer that's actually
put in that structure.
So there's a very complicated
private-public ownership issue
here at stake.
And that's why the politics
and the policies around crystal
management can be
fairly complicated.
So I kind of hold
you the bad side.
I've told you the negative
effects of shoreline hardening.
But there are alternatives.
There are ways that we can
protect private property
from these coastal hazards
without compromising
the habitat.
At least that's what
a lot of the NGOs
and some of NOAA's
group has been trying
to do in the last
couple decades has
developed these types of
structures, these living
shorelines.
And really, when I came
into graduate school
one of the first
things I wanted to do
was actually test
whether or not they
were functionally equivalent
to a natural or pristine
shoreline.
So this is a NOAA definition
for a living shoreline.
But really what you
want to take from this
is that it has to have some
kind of living component.
There can be a structural
element, an artificial element.
You can have rocks out,
but you have to have marsh.
You have to have mangrove.
You have to have some
kind of living component
to the shoreline for it
to be considered for NOAA
and for a lot of the
NOS's supporting this,
a living shoreline.
And here are some examples
from North Carolina
for estaurine shorelines.
And I should say
for the open coast,
beach June grass
would be equivalent
if you wanted to have an
open ocean living shoreline.
So this is a morel sill
with some marsh behind it.
This is a granite sill
with marsh on this side.
And then this is actually
a loose oyster sill
that we constructed while
I was in graduate school
along a really eroded shoreline
as part of an Estaurine
Research Reserve.
And this over time
accululated live oyster
and became a living oyster reef.
So for the work that I was
doing in graduate school,
I really wanted
to understand, OK,
we have these sill structures
we want to put out.
We want to plant marsh.
We want to create
a living shoreline.
Is it really truly equivalent
to a natural shoreline?
And so, this is
kind of my schematic
of what a natural
estaurine shoreline would
look like in North Carolina.
You would have salt marsh.
You'd have intertidal
oyster reef
and then you'd have
some sea grass.
Well, in a lot of places
in North Carolina,
oysters have been
degraded and largely lost.
So a lot of these
fringing marshes
are eroding because they don't
have this natural kind of shore
protection anymore in
the form of oyster reefs.
So I decided to compare these
shorelines that are currently
eroding and might end
up being bulkheaded
because the private
property owner doesn't
want their property to
erode, and compare them
to this newer technique, which
is to put a rock still out
in front.
And then also compare it
to the traditional way,
which would have been
to put a bulkhead up,
and then the thought
being you would eventually
lose the marsh over time.
So I sampled bulkheads
for the marsh,
had basically
already disappeared.
I sampled sills with marsh
and then marsh alone.
And so this first
graph is just showing
you kind of a snapshot of
some of the work that I did.
But it's a catch
per unit effort.
So it's basically the number
of individuals that we caught.
And the first graph is
just comparing our control,
which is the salt
marshes that have
lost that intertidal oysterie
to a marsh with that rock
sill out in front.
The black bars are the
number of fish we caught
and the gray bars are the number
of crustacians that we caught,
so blue crabs and shrimp.
And what we see here is
that we actually see,
not only are we providing
equivalent habitat,
we're actually
seeing enhancement.
So we have a higher
abundance and this also
applies in terms of total
diversity of fishing
crustaceans occupying these
marshes that have sills
in front relative
to control marshes.
And one of the
thoughts might be that
because these marshes typically
had oyster reef in front
of them, but that those had
been lost through overharvest
and erosion, that that rock,
that actually colonizes
oysters, is serving
as a substitute
for that natural structure.
So would obviously not be
the same in other regions
that don't have
intertidal oysters.
You would be thinking about
it a little bit differently.
But here it seems
to be a substitution
in terms of habitat.
And in terms of
who's present, we
have a lot of small kind of
estuarine, marsh-dependent
species like mummichogs
and killifish.
But we also start to see
some of the commercially
and recreationally
valuable species.
In North Carolina, [? retrome ?]
is extremely recreationally
valuable, blue crab,
speckled trout, flounder,
and snapper species, also
some pig fish, all of these
are species that people
are actively fishing for.
So it's important not only just
for the ecological function,
but also for the fisheries,
kind of tying back
to the original reason we
care about coastal ecosystems.
Now for the second
part of the study,
we decided to go ahead and
sample bulkheads as well.
So these are bulkheads
without any marsh in front.
Same types of marshes and
then marshes with sills.
And we did a more
targeted sampling
to get at these marsh-dependent
organisms, so these killifish,
these smaller organisms
seem to really need marsh
for them to want to
be in this habitat.
And so what we see
is that again we
see an enhancement, although
not significant, of fish
when you add the sill in front
of the control marsh, and then
a definite significant increase
relative to the bulkhead.
So the bulkhead has
many fewer organisms,
particularly these
marsh-dependent organisms
than the sill or
the control marsh.
And so in the control we tend
to see some general species that
are using these habitats.
In the sill we tend
to see some more reef
or oyster associated
species that are added.
So this is starting to kind
of get at some explanation
as to who is really
inhabiting these habitat.
But when you get
to the bulkhead,
you actually only have
your generalist species.
So you essentially have
your marsh residents
plus generalists,
marsh residents
plus reef associated
species like sheepshead.
And then when you
have the bulkhad,
you go back to
generalist species.
So this is kind of getting more
at the composition of who's
really utilizing these habitats.
So just to provide
some conclusions here,
living shorelines we think so
far, not based just on the work
I've done, but what
others have done,
can serve as better habitat
for fish and crustaceans
in bulkheads.
And that at least
in North Carolina
where you have
intertidal oysteries,
they're functionally
similar to oyster reefs
in terms of forage and
refuge opportunities.
So I want to shift gears now
and talk about another aspect
of shorelines.
And that's really
whether or not we
are creating sustainable,
resilient shorelines
so we might find that
these living shorelines are
ecologically better
than bulkheads.
But if they don't
perform in terms
of providing erosion
protection, no one's
actually going to want
to implement them.
They're going to want to stick
with the status quo, which
is bulkheads.
So while I was in
graduate school,
Hurricane Irene came through
North Carolina in 2011.
And it was about the middle
of my graduate career,
so I had sampled a lot of
sites before the storm,
and I was able to go back and
sample sites after the storm.
And what I did initially
was just go along the areas
that I knew that were hardest
hit by the hurricane and survey
first just what type
of shoreline was there,
just driving along in a
boat with a GPS and a camera
and documenting the
type of shoreline there.
So these are just regions
that I sampled and the kind.
What I want to point
out here is that you
have a pretty good mix.
You have a lot of
natural shoreline,
but you also have a lot of
hardened shoreline here.
And it's mostly bulkheads, so
this is the bulkhead shoreline.
And what I decided
to do was that I
looked to the
engineering literature,
because I'm an ecologist and
I was like how do I really
quantify damage to
shoreline structures?
And I came across the
engineering article that
basically said they do
a visual classification
and they assess whether
or not the structure
is intact and performing the
function that it was intended.
And so they had a classification
of landward erosion,
which is shown here.
So the structure is
intact, but the land
that it's supposed to be
protecting has eroded away.
So that's one
category of the image.
The structure might
be intact but you have
some kind of structural damage.
So you have pieces
of the structure
that are starting to fall away.
That's another category of
damage you could assess.
You could have a breach.
So the structure is still
there, but it's actually
compromised in some way
and the erosion of the land
is actually occurring
behind the structure.
And then you can have a
complete failure or a collapse.
And so this is
what was shown here
where the bulkhead
itself has actually
fallen into the water and all of
the land has then eroded away.
And so what this
graph is showing you
is that for these
different regions
how much of the
bulkheaded shoreline
suffered some kind of damage.
And so these three
regions really
had low percentages of damage.
But in this one particular area
that seemed to be hardest hit,
75% of the bulkheads
had some kind of damage.
And I only show bulkheads
here because none
of the other types of
shoreline exhibited any damage.
So the structure that was
most commonly implemented
for protection was actually
the one most readily damaged
in a Category 1 hurricane.
And that's not even
a big hurricane.
So that's not Superstorm Sandy.
Irene was a blip compared to
what we saw in the Northeast.
And I love to put
pictures, because I
think they really kind of
sell the story even better.
And these are two properties
that are roughly 500 feet away
from each other.
They're on the same shoreline.
I've been sampling these
properties for years.
This property owner, Mr.
Avery, has a bulkhead.
That's just an arrow
to show for reference.
Mr. Shallcross had a
living shoreline put in.
This is a picture I took
one year before the storm
where we actually planted
the marsh grass for him.
And this is actually
right after the hurricane,
so the water level
is still pretty high.
His bulkhead
completely collapsed.
He lost, he said, about
22 truckloads of sediment,
which he then put back in
and rebuilt his bulkhead,
I think for about $20,000,
even though I walked him down
and I showed him that
this property actually
had no damage except for other
people's bulkheads and docks.
So the only damage Jim
really suffered with his deck
was damaged by pilings,
bulkhead material washing up.
So no rocks out of place.
I mean the marsh actually
looks a lot better.
So this is obviously
a year later.
The plans have grown
up, but the water
is really only high because it
was still high after the storm.
I showed Mr. Ackery
this property
and he said that he was
trying to sell his house.
And he said I will
probably be able to sell it
for more if I rebuild the
bulkhead because people
like bulkheads.
So that's that's happened.
And so, I show
you those pictures
but I also wanted to make
sure, just because sometimes it
can be hard to actually quantify
damage to a natural shoreline,
that we weren't just
observing-- it wasn't just
that we weren't able
to detect the damage
that these shorelines
were experiencing.
And so I had a series of natural
marsh shorelines and shorelines
with a sill.
So the black is the
sill and the open circle
are these marsh shorelines.
And I was able to
sample a year before,
right after, and then a
year after the hurricane.
This is the surface
elevation of that site.
So surface elevation is
essentially a proxy for
whether or not it's eroding.
If the elevation
doesn't change, it's
not eroding, if it drops
it means it's eroding.
We saw no change in
those sites through time.
And then this is
vegetation density.
So this is the actual number
of plants in the marsh.
And we did see a
drop in the plants.
So these lines were
affected by the hurricane.
But the neat part is
that particularly when
you had a sill, those plants
rebounded naturally within one
year.
So this is really getting
more to the resilience
part of the shoreline.
This property owner, Mr.
Shallcross, his shoreline
is part of this data set.
He's not having to do
anything to his shoreline
for it to recover
from a storm event.
So it's not only that they
sustain the shoreline better
by preventing erosion,
but they're also
more resilient in terms of
rebounding from the bulkheads.
We're continuing
some of this work.
I have a graduate student
at UNC that I'm currently
working with, where this
was one storm event.
It could have just
been the perfect storm
to for marshes to do well and
for bulkheads to do poorly.
So we decided that we were
going to continue this work.
And she actually went out
after hurricane Arthur
in 2014, another category
1 storm, slightly different
in that it came in
a different tide,
so the storm surge
was different.
It was a much
faster moving storm.
So the impacts were
potentially very different.
And so she's actually
analyzing these data now.
But she went back
to the same places
I did, did the same assessments.
And we're going to see
if we see similar trends
with the second hurricane.
And we're combining this with
a little bit of social science.
So a colleague of mine at
Northeastern University,
Steven Scyphers, does a lot
of socioeconomic surveys.
And so we have a grant
where we surveyed
through online and
postcard mailings
approximately 850 waterfront
residents in North Carolina.
And we've asked them questions
about their perceptions
of shoreline hardening in
terms of whether they think
it's effective or durable by
type, whether it's a bulkhead,
or riprap or living shoreline.
And we've also asked
them to tell us
how much damage they've
had, what's caused it,
and what it costs them in terms
of repair and maintenance.
And so we're just starting
to look at the data now.
So I'm just showing you a
few graphs from the work
that Carter has
really been leading.
These top graphs
are the percentage
of respondents that report
any kind of damage at all
or any kind of maintenance cost.
And then these are
the respondents
that if they report
damage costs, how much,
and if they report
maintenance costs, how much.
And so what I really
want to highlight here
is that these natural
shorelines, so predominantly
marsh shorelines are
lower in terms of just
whether they report damage
at all or maintenance at all.
So there's a lot of people
who are reporting no damage
or maintenance the entire
lifetime of their shoreline.
And then even if they are
reporting damage or maintenance
costs, they are
significantly lower
than these bulkhead shorelines,
which are most common.
Riprap is the other shoreling
that we're really not sure,
we think riprap tends to be
more resilient than bulkheading,
just because it's rock
kind of piled on shore.
And so it's not suffering
from the same kind
of structural failure.
But we're still kind of
exploring, because many,
many fewer people have riprap
shorelines in North Carolina
than bulkhead shorelining.
So I kind of want to finish with
kind of a thought about what
it would really
take to get people
to shift to living shorelines.
So we've shown you the ecology.
We showed you a little
bit of the engineering.
We've also showed you a
little bit of the cost.
But people are still
resistant to change.
They like the status quo.
They like what they've
known for decades.
Bulkheads have been
something we've
used for a long time
along our coastlines.
And so this is work by
our colleague, Steven,
where he's surveyed
people and asked them,
would they be willing to
try a living shoreline?
And initially he
just surveyed them
and asked them that
simple question.
And in Alabama, 60%, no way.
They want a bulkhead.
But then he asked, well what if
we had some kind of cost share,
and he varied the amount of
money that was cost shared.
So the State would maybe give
you a tax credit for instance.
And the remarkable part is that
people were really much more
likely to consider it.
40% of the people changed their
mind a little bit and said,
yeah, maybe I would
be a little unsure
or maybe I would be even
likely to build a living
shoreline if all of
the cost wasn't on me.
We did have roughly 6%
of Alabama respondents
who actually went in
the other direction.
And that's because
they were people
who commented and believed
that they don't want
the government spending
taxpayer dollars on any kind
of private property.
So that's that 6%
that you see there.
And so this is just a
picture of a conversion
of a bulkhead to a living
shoreline, where they've
actually not removed this
bulkhead, they've essentially
filled in on top of
it and planed marsh.
So this is something they're
trying with NGOs and with cost
incentives in some areas.
And we're starting to
see some progress there.
So that's kind of the positive
note I want to end on,
is that living shorelines are
a viable option in some places.
It's not going to
work everywhere.
And with the right amount
of education and incentives,
it's possible we could push
private property owners
in the direction of
thinking about the long term
sustainability and resilience
and ecological function
of the shorelines,
rather than just, I
want my property to stay exactly
the way it is for the next 30
years.
So with that I just want to
thank all of my collaborators,
my co-authors, funding
sources over my graduate work
and my postdoc work.
And if you have more
questions, Steven
has developed this
shoreline site
where you can actually post
your own personal experiences
if you're a private homeowner to
this site with your shoreline.
You can even contact
us and we can send you
a camera, if you're
willing to take pictures
during storm events.
And we have some lab
pages and Twitter
account if you want to
get in touch with me.
So, thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
-OK, thank you, Rachel, i
was bursting with questions.
But I have to stick to my
own self-imposed format.
Yeah, you'll have to wait.
So as I said, we'll have
the two talks and then
a question and answer session
and then a short break.
So our next speaker is
Anna Sirovic, Anna Sirovic.
Sorry.
She's a researcher in
the marine bioacoustics
lab at Scripps, and
in particular focusing
on marine bioacoustics,
and in particular
of exploited marine mammals,
which I take to mean
whales and that sort of thing.
So I don't know why,
but I have to come up
with some anecdote for
each talk or at least
something that fascinated me.
And I guess, although
I knew that whales talk
to each other I grew up hearing
about songs of humpback whales,
I only recently heard an
anecdote which I really
have to track down.
I have to try this that
evidently Inouit, a group
of Inouit in what used to be
the Northwest Territories, which
guess in now the Netsilik
Territory in Canada,
they would hunt whales.
The way they would
find whales is
to take a paddle,
their kayak paddle,
and put it in the water put
their ear next to the paddle
blade, and they
could actually hear
when the whales were close by.
And that would be how they
would know they were close
and they could actually
go on the hunt.
So apparently
bioacoustics has been
known to humans for
years and years,
but it's now being
used to understand them
and unfortunately, one of
the byproducts of humans
is to pollute just
about everything
we can get our hands on.
So we have light
pollution in the sky
and we have noise
pollution in the oceans.
So anyway, Anna.
[APPLAUSE]
-So thank you for
the introduction.
And my career as
a bioacoustician,
I've been spanning
the fields of biology
and engineering pretty
much this whole time.
And so I do much
less well with jokes.
So I promise that my
title is the only pun
I'm going to try on you.
But I do promise to play
you a lot of sounds,
because I think that's the
really cool part and the really
fascinating part
about all of this.
But what I will tell you about
today is two kind of stories,
two different examples of
how I, with my colleagues,
have been using
sounds that animals
make to learn more about
endangered marine species.
And I'll have an example about
blue whales and another example
on grouper and fish, to
see how we can learn more
about the populations and
use it for better management
approaches.
So ocean is in fact
a very noisy place,
partly because sound in the
ocean travels really well.
It travels much further
than light does.
So a lot of animals use
it then to communicate.
Because it's a lot harder to
see things in the ocean than it
is to hear things.
And among [INAUDIBLE]
it's not just the animals
that are making sounds.
Just about anything in and
around the ocean make sounds.
So first of all, there's
lots of natural sources
of sound in the ocean,
things like rain, waves,
or even earthquakes.
They are, let's see if
can play this for you.
They're kind of intermittent
sources of sound, so.
[RAINSTORM SOUNDS]
Sounds like thunder.
But it's really the sound of an
earthquake underwater recorded
by hydrophones.
And a lot of these natural
sources, what I call them,
are very low frequency,
kind of low pitched,
kind of like you
heard that sound.
In addition to these
sounds, lots of animals
make sounds, not just
whales, which are probably
the ones you're
most familiar with,
but also fish and invertebrates
also make a lot of sounds.
So just a couple of examples
I want to play for you.
I'm not going to play humpback
whale songs because everybody
has heard those.
But here one example, this
is a sperm whale clicking.
[CLICKING]
Sperm whales use these
clicks for echolocaiton,
similar to what bats are doing.
But then, rather than
playing you a humpback song,
I want to play you
in minke whale song.
And this is a minke
whale that you
would hear if you went off shore
here in the Atlantic somewhere
and stuck your
head in the ocean.
Because, you can in
fact, if you are even
swimming around or diving,
you can hear these animals.
They're so loud that
you can often hear them
if they're in the vicinity.
[HEARTBEAT SOUNDS]
Now, a couple of unique things
about this minke whale song
is that actually, if you
notice, it is very long.
It will just go on for a while.
And I am playing
this at regular speed
as it was recorded in the ocean.
So this is literally
what you would
hear if you go
out there and just
were in the vicinity of one.
[HEARTBEAT SOUNDS]
And so this repetitive nature
is also one of the features
that we see commonly,
particularly for baleen whales,
where they're just making sounds
over and over and over again.
But another interesting part,
speeding up a little bit.
Sometimes they slow down.
Sometimes to speed up.
Sometimes they keep it constant.
We don't really know why.
But so as you said, this
is what minke whales here
in the Atlantic sound like.
If you went into
the Pacific, they
sound totally different there.
And this is also a common
thing I'll get to in a minute.
But I just wanted to entice you
with that piece of information
here.
But then of course another
important source of sound
is us humans.
Shipping is a huge contributor
to the low frequency noise.
So you can hear the
propellers of boats.
And so again, this
is a type of sound,
because they are
typically low frequency,
they will travel
over long distances
and can contribute
to increased noise
levels across large areas.
But there are other, also
anthropogenic sources,
such as oil and gas exploration
that are large contributors
of ocean noise pollution, as are
even things that echo sounders.
When you're going out fishing
and your little fish finder
is on, that's loud and
noisy navy sonar, et cetera.
So to listen to all
these kinds of sounds,
we use a variety of
underwater recording devices.
And since I'm mostly interested
in long term trends and changes
over a long time, what
I've mostly been using
are autonomous
recorders that you
can deploy on the ocean floor
for extended periods of time,
and they just record
all the sounds
over a certain bandwidth, over
a certain frequency range.
And all of these devices,
they have the same features.
They are fundamentally
the same things.
They consist of a
hydrophone, which
is an underwater microphone.
They have a data logging
system of some sort, hard disk
to store the data--
we have to retrieve
the instruments typically to
get our data back and download
them.
Batteries, and so those
two factors the batteries
and the hard disk
space are going
to limit how long
you can actually
deploy them on the ocean floor.
On the left hand
side, I'm showing you
this is an instrument that
we built in house at Scripps.
Typically it's a
fairly large device.
It's called a high frequency
acoustic recording package.
And we can deploy these
instruments for up to a year,
recording at very
large bandwidth,
leave them in deep water.
And when we retrieve
them, get information
on a plethora of anthropogenic
sounds and animal sounds
and any other kind of geographic
or physical sounds as well.
On the right hand
side, I'm showing you
an example of a recorder that's
actually an off the shelf
recorder you can just buy.
It's actually a company here in
Massachusetts that makes them.
And we've been using this for
some of the shallow water,
shorter deployments.
This is actually
from the grouper work
that I'll be talking about.
So there's a variety of
possibilities and scales
in which these instruments come.
But again, the idea is to get
long term records of sounds
from underwater.
And once we have
these records, we
can learn a lot about
the actual animals
that are making those sounds.
We can learn a lot about
their distribution, also
population structure or trends,
because most of the animals
have species specific calls.
Sometimes they're
even area specific.
We can learn about
behavior because they
produce different
calls, depending
on their behavioral state.
If they're hungry or if
they're looking for a mate,
just like humans they're
going to say different things.
And then ultimately,
we want to apply this
to species management or to also
understand how us humans are
impacting the animals.
So, with that introduction, let
me start with the first case
study.
I want to talk about
blue whales for a minute.
And blue whales, I
don't know if any of you
have ever had the fortune
of seeing a blue whale,
but they're awesome animals.
They are the largest
animal that has ever lived.
They are bigger
than any dinosaur.
They can be up to 30
meters long, or 100 feet,
if you prefer that system.
They can weigh up to 200 tons.
It's a massive, massive thing.
And we find them across
all of the world's oceans.
They are migratory animals,
like most of the other baleen
whales.
They spend winters in kind of
lower latitudes, warmer waters,
mating and breeding and they
travel to higher latitude
regions that are more
productive and they feed there
during the summer.
Currently, we know there's
at least three subspecies
of blue whales.
The Antarctic blue whale
is the largest of them.
This is the one that's up to 100
feet long and 30 meters long.
They're found around
the Antarctic continent.
They were the primary target
of the whaling industry
in the early 20th
century because they
have a lot of blubber,
which meant a lot of oil
that the whaling
industry was after.
The second subspecies are
the pygmy blue whales.
They're really
pygmy little things.
They only are about 24
meters long, still quite
substantial in weight
as well, because they
tend to be shorter in stock.
They have shorter
tail and longer heads.
So still provide a lot of oil.
They're initially found
in the Indian Ocean.
So we constrain that subspecies
to that geographic region.
And then finally, all
of the other blue whales
in other oceans,
we just put them
all in the same subspecies of
just your general blue whale.
Now the reason why
I study blue whales
is that they actually
are very vocal.
They produce songs that
are quite distinct.
They're very low frequency,
kind of low pitched songs
and they're very loud.
They can travel over
very long distances.
And about 10 years ago,
Mark McDonald and colleagues
offered this hypothesis
that the different songs
that blue whales sing
in different populations
might actually indicate
separate populations.
Rather than having
these three subspecies,
we might think of it in a
little bit finer scales.
Because we know that even
though I said that they're
found in all the world's
oceans, they are really distinct
populations in
places where we do
and we don't see blue whales.
And so this map shows
that information
based on these different
songs of blue whales
where we know and
see them occurring.
And so for example,
off the coast
of California,
Washington, and Oregon,
there is one
population that moves
from Central America up
to Southern California
and up the Gulf of
Alaska seasonally.
There is also another
population that's
more kind of in the Central
and Western Pacific.
There's a population of blue
whales offshore here as well.
But then in the
Southern hemisphere
we have a couple of different
populations in the Southern
Indian Ocean and one
in the Northern Indian.
And then this
Antarctic blue whale
that is the largest
of them all down
circumpolarly around Antarctica.
And so, let me play for you
a couple of their songs,
because I want to demonstrate
to you how they're actually
very different.
So you'll be able to hear them.
Now actually to hear them,
I had to speed them up.
Like I said, they're
very, very low pitched.
They're below our hearing.
But I've sped all of
these songs four times,
which means that they are
four times higher frequency.
So that's the first part.
[SOFT BEEPING SOUND]
And four times shorter
duration, so they're
really faster than
they would be usually.
So this up here
is a spectrogram.
That's a way that we represent
kind of visually sounds.
And it's time on the x-axis
and frequency on the y-axis.
So that first pulsing
bit is this right here
and then the tone
is the second part.
So that is our North
East Pacific Blue Whale.
Just for comparison,
let me play to you
the blue whales as they
sound off of Australia.
[WHOOSHING, HUMMING SOUND]
And again, these are
sped up four times
like the previous
ones, so you can
hear there's a different
pattern to them.
[HUMMING SOUND]
So now we're having
a little bit of gap.
[LOW HUMMING SOUND]
I want to also play for you
the Antarctic blue whale calls.
And so here it's harder
to see them here.
But these little blips
down here, they're
Antarctic blue whale calls.
You'll notice they look a
lot less complex than some
of these other ones.
And they're also
much lower frequency.
So you will have a really
hard time hearing these,
even though again, they're
sped up four times.
It's much simpler,
and quite a bit lower.
So like I said, these
songs, as far as we know,
we believe that they're produced
primarily or exclusively
by males.
We know that it's true
for the blue whales
off the Northeast in
the Northeast Pacific.
So we're assuming they have
some sort of a mating function.
But the details are of that
a still a little bit unsure.
Now that I've introduced
you to the whale songs,
I want to tell you a little
bit about the whaling
and the management of
whales kind of worldwide,
because I think it's a very
interesting and informative
story.
So, the International
Whaling Commission
is the international
organization
that was founded in 1946, when
the whale populations worldwide
were in heavy declines with the
goal of managing the whaling so
that they can continue
whaling for a long time.
And as their system
of management,
they had a quota system
where each country,
each whaling country was
assigned a certain number
of blue whale units.
Now, a blue whale unit is
a very interesting measure
because it's a measure
of how much oil you
get from the whale.
And so one blue whale
unit was one blue whale
or it was a two fin whales, 2
and 1/2 humpbacks, or six sei
whales.
So each country would get a
certain number of blue whale
units, and they could catch
it in any kind of combination
of all these different species.
And so what that
contributed to was
quite a rapid kind of
successive depletion
of all the different species.
Because the whalers
could just keep going out
and collecting
whatever they found.
But as the blue whales were
becoming more and more rare,
whenever they found
one, they would still
catch it, because it was
quite valuable to catch them.
Until finally in
1966, their numbers
had dropped so much that they
became protected worldwide.
It took another 20 years for
a global whaling moratorium
to come into place, because
all of the populations
kept decreasing.
And since then the
IWC has been tasked,
not just with
management of whaling,
but also has expanded its
mission to conservation
of whales themselves.
So currently, one
of the major things
that they are
interested in working on
is stock assessment as
a part of understanding
of how the populations are
recovering post whaling.
But then also to be able to do
this kind of stock assessment,
we really need to know a lot
more about the population
structure of animals.
So over the years, they go
through different species
and different stocks and
try to understand and use
the available scientific
information to delineate
and then get a better sense
of how to properly assess
these stocks and populations.
And so the current focus are
the pygmy blue whales, so
these smaller, chubbier
Southern hemisphere animals.
And just last week,
I was actually
at the meeting of the scientific
committee of the International
Whaling Commission where a
large variety of scientists
were brought in to
provide information
and all kind of best known
available science on genetics
and acoustics of these
two species to try
is to help form a picture of
how these populations look.
So what I'm showing you here,
the map on the bottom, this
is the map of all
the locations where
genetic samples, so basically
tissues of blue whales
are available to do
genetic analysis,
to compare genetic difference
between the pygmy blue whales.
And so there's a
lot of data that
were collected off of Chile.
In the Indian Ocean, there
are some of Madagascar, South
Africa, a little
bit here of India,
but most samples really come
from waters off Australia.
And when doing
meta data analysis,
they just found that the
populations in the Indian Ocean
and off Chile are actually
as different from each other
as this pygmy blue whale that I
told you, the subspecies exist
that is from the
Indian Ocean, is
from the Antarctic subspecies.
So there is genetic evidence to
say that the Chilean population
should be its own subspecies.
But then we also
looked at acoustics
and how do the different
acoustic stocks map
into this genetic variability?
And what we find--
so again, this
is now a map of all the places
where different blue whale
songs were recorded in
the Southern hemisphere.
And different symbols
are different song types.
And you'll see that there
is actually a lot more data
that we have than they've
had in the genetic data.
And what we have found
is that-- so this
is an update of the work that
McDonald and colleagues did
before.
And we have found that
in a lot of these places,
their initial maps and
hypotheses were actually
pretty good in terms of where
the animals occur that sing
these particular songs.
But then interestingly,
here off Chile,
we do have two different
song types that
occur at the same times
and places at all times,
and they match that
genetic population
that is distinct from
the Indian Ocean.
But based on our data
in the Indian Ocean,
we have at least three
different populations,
acoustic populations,
if you will for now.
So there is the turquoise
diamonds, the red triangles,
and the red triangles is that
an Australian song, and then
the yellow crosses.
There's also this little
other diamond up here,
but that is a new song
type that hasn't quite
been confirmed if it's a blue
whale or not but likely is.
And what you can see when you
map the places and times when
these different songs occur, is
that Eastern and Western Indian
Ocean songs are distinct and
occur at different places.
Northern Indian song is
also different from them,
and it's also
spatially separated.
And there's this area in
the Central Indian Ocean
where there is some
overlap between the songs.
But Northern Indian Ocean song
is never there at the same time
when the Southern
songs are there.
And so what the geneticists have
said, seeing this information
is, well OK, we really don't
have very much data here
from the Western Indian Ocean.
But based on this
information so far,
we have reason to think that the
population of Australia and off
of Madagascar
could be different.
So one of the outcomes
of the meeting
is for a recommendation
that was put forward
that there should be
more data collected,
genetic data collected, in
the Western Indian Ocean
so that the
comparison of genetics
can be done between these
two populations to see if
and how different
they actually are.
At the same time, it was also
useful for the acoustics people
in the crowd to talk to
geneticists, because what
we found-- from
genetic data also
they found of the
animals off of Australia
and New Zealand in
the small samples
that they currently have, there
aren't genetic differences
necessarily that are obvious.
And when you talk to
geneticists they'll
give you different answers
to how strongly they
believe that indicates
that those are really
indeed same populations
or same substocks.
But geneticists have
actually really good ways
of looking quantitatively
at difference
between the DNA of animals.
And what we have done
so far as a community,
as an acoustics
community, is look
at more of the differences
in song in a qualitative way
to delineate these
different things.
So by working with
geneticists, there's
hope that we can develop
more quantitative tools
to compare how different
these songs actually are.
Because if you remember when
I played you these songs,
a couple of them
were very similar.
And some of these songs here
in the Southern hemisphere,
they're quite similar
to each other.
But they're very different
from the Antarctic song,
and they're very different from
some of the Northern hemisphere
songs.
So if we can measure
the amount of difference
in songs of different
populations,
we could also form
more refined hypotheses
and how likely they
are to actually
be difference of populations.
So that's kind of a
large scale story.
On a finer scale
story, by looking
at some of the song variability
in the North Pacific,
we have found that even one song
that we thought was the same
may be not quite true.
So here I'm showing you,
this is the first song
that I played you, the
tonal part of it in Southern
California and off of Alaska
that we record regularly.
And by visual
inspection, if you've
seen enough of
these at least, it
becomes apparent that there
is this little kink here
in the Gulf of Alaska
song, where the frequencies
get kind of steps down a bit.
And so when we looked at this
in a little bit more detail,
we found that in
fact-- so this is now
from many measured calls
in the Gulf of Alaska
and Southern California over
a couple of different years.
We find that, in fact, the
step in the Gulf of Alaska
is much more prominent than
it is in Southern California.
But the question is, is
that really important
and how does it
matter to the whales?
Now we don't quite
know that yet.
But what we do see is in
addition to this step-- now
I've put this in
the same y axis here
and you'll notice that this
call is much higher frequency
than that call.
It's about one and one
half Hertz difference,
which may seem trivial.
However, we know that
blue whales actually
slowly over time are
decreasing their frequency.
Their calls are getting
lower and lower pitched.
And the difference between
these two call types
is about eight years
of frequency shift.
So that makes me think that
these guys are actually
separate and they're
not necessarily
communicating with each other,
at least in the same way.
So I think we've made
some good progress
in using these large scale
distinctions in a song
to get some idea of
population variability.
But we're really
getting to the point
where we can think of some
finer scale differences
and how much difference in
population they may imply.
Also does this
particular [INAUDIBLE]
I told you about Northeast
Pacific song difference is
interesting or relevant
because we have known
that the global
population of California
has been stable for
the last 20 years
or so, which is not quite what
people expect because they're
supposed to be increasing
and recovering from whaling.
And one of the ongoing
questions is, why are they not?
And it's possible that they're
expanding their range, which
is kind of the going
hypothesis as they're just
moving to different areas.
But these differences
in songs may
indicate that that's not
entirely the whole story,
that it might be something
else going on there,
that these maybe are somehow
different populations.
So the next challenge
for us is going
to be to figure out how to use
these acoustics to actually do
abundance estimates.
This is one thing that's really
important for the managers,
both from the Navy perspective
but also in the International
Whaling Commission
community to be
able to enhance the application
of these data further.
So next, I'm going to
shift gears altogether,
and I want to talk about another
group of animals that is just
as commercially
important, and I would
argue, maybe close to
being as charismatic,
which are groupers.
They are really charismatic.
Nassau grouper for
example, they're
famous for being very friendly.
Divers love them, because
if you go on a reef,
they'll come up to you.
They're this huge fish.
It's an impressive experience
if you ever had it.
It's as impressive as it is to
see a blue whale in the ocean.
it's just as impressive to
have a giant fish come up
to your face and say hello.
[INAUDIBLE]
They're about five, I
think, five, six feet long.
They can be pretty a big fish.
And so, they're ecologically
important on reefs
because they are
voracious predators.
They are the top down
control to the reefs.
They're commercially important
because they're very tasty.
And they also have
this recreational value
because people like
seeing them on the reefs
and like swimming with them.
There's a number
of other species
of groupers that are common,
found through the Atlantic
and in the reefs
of the Atlantic.
But many of groupers, they
have this unfortunate spawning
behavior where fish from all
around will come and aggregate
in one place at a very
predictable time, every year,
same place, same time to spawn.
They will make
these aggregations
of thousands of fish,
which then make them very
susceptible to overfishing.
Because if you're a fisherman,
you know the fish are there,
you drop your hook
and line and you
can decimate that population
in a matter of days.
Now luckily for me, these
guys make also lots of sounds.
So let me show you
what they sound like.
[CLICKING AND GROANING SOUNDS]
So that was a Red
hind group where
they very common in
the site in the Caymans
where we've been working.
[CLICKING AND GROANING SOUNDS]
That's a Nassau grouper.
They're a little bit grumpier.
So, what we have been doing
in the last couple of years
is working on
Little Cayman, this
is actually a very
special place,
where a new, well new
to humans, aggregation,
spawning aggregation was
discovered in the early 2000s.
So the Caymans are
a three island chain
in the middle of the
Caribbean, just South of Cuba.
And Little Cayman is
the smallest of them.
And here on the west
side, in early 2000s,
the fishermen discovered a
previously unknown spawning
aggregation.
They started fishing it hard.
The numbers plummeted.
Caymanian government
however, stepped in,
stopped fishing, and
started encouraging research
in this location to
learn more about how
we can protect these
animals so that we
can have sustainable fishery
and keep them under reefs.
And in the time since, in
the last 10 or 12 years,
the Grouper Moon
Project has been
composed of a
variety of scientists
who have gone out and
done numerous dives
on and around the spawning site
to study more and understand
better the spawning
biology, the interchange
of different populations
and things like that.
We joined them a
year and a half ago
and put recorders down,
because prior to us
joining the-- so the
groupers spawn at dusk.
And the divers would go down,
observe spawning events,
but then it would get dark.
So we didn't really
know how much longer.
Does the spawning just
happen during that time?
What did the fish do afterwards?
Did they disperse?
Are they still in the
same spot on the reef?
Kind of the dynamics of the
movements were highly unknown.
So we put a number of
recorders at the site,
had all kinds of misfortunes
and adventures in doing so.
But we've had some
really exciting data
and really interesting things.
And this is mostly work
that my student, Casey,
has been pushing through on.
And so one of the
approaches that we took
is using what's called
soundscape analysis, which
is kind of this large
scale of looking
at the whole spectrum of sounds,
and trying to divide it up
into different bands
that are of interest.
And so what she has done,
you can see here again,
these are spectrograms
of different grouper
sounds in the top panel.
And you can see
there's a lot of energy
in most of these calls up
the few hundred Hertz range.
Once you get lower, even though
there's a lot of call activity
there as well there's a lot
of anthropogenic sounds.
So she was looking for a
fine balance between the two.
And then at higher frequency,
we get a lot of other fish
sounds, a lot of naturally
squirrel fish, which
are quite abundant on the reef.
And so what she has
done is gone through
and measured five
minutes and then
one hour averages
of sound levels
for these two frequency
bands over the times
of our whole deployments.
And first what we looked
at is how do the fish daily
soundscape change
during the first period
we had recorders out in 2015.
So just as a cue, I'm using
a little picture of Nassau,
as the Serranidae as the
grouper band descripter
and then this is our
little squirrel fish that
is representing other fish.
And so on these plots, this
is about six days of data,
the gray shaded boxes
represent nighttime.
And what you can see
there is the blue
is the five minute
averages, and the black
is the one hour averages.
So you see there's a lot
of variability from five
minute to five minute interval.
But when you sum
over that, there
is a bit of a nocturnal
peak just at about sunset.
But I should also point
out that during this year
at this particular site, Nassau
grouper spawning occurred
on these two nights, and then
back here in these last three
nights, it was tiger
grouper spawning period.
And you can see that during
the tiger spawning grouper
particular, there is a little
bit stronger signals because we
actually had more tiger
grouper on our particular site
this year.
But you see some of
these daily patterns.
Same is true for
the squirrel fish,
but they have a very
clear corpuscular pattern
with peaks at dusk and dawn
and relatively lower levels
during the day.
Now in addition to the
daily cycle in calls,
there's also changes
in the local activity
with lunar phase.
Spawning often happens,
or generally happens,
sometime around usually a
few days after a new moon.
And so here I'm showing
six days at a period
in between the moon phases.
This plot is the new moon and
this plot shows the full moon
time period.
And what I just want you
to take home from this
is that the average level,
so basically average noise
of this band of grouper sounds
is substantially higher.
Two to three DB, while it
doesn't sound much this
is a logarithmic scale.
So it's actually quite
a substantial increase
during the new and full moons.
So the animals are
a lot more active
during those other times.
We found the same pattern for
the squirrel fish as well.
But then what we
really want to know
is, do these metrics
actually represent fish?
Can we certainly say that these
are fish that we are detecting?
And so what Casey has
done is gone through
and logged painfully all
of the calls that have
occurred over those six days.
And that was about 20,000
calls that she's gone through.
They're basically
identified by species.
A lot of them are Red hinds,
but we have quite a variety
of animals in there.
And the blue line here
in both of these plots
show the number of
calls at any given hour.
And then the black is still
the soundscape metric.
And you'll notice, when doing
cross correlations in these,
you see that [INAUDIBLE] are
relationship between the two.
So there is some
indication that they
are good proxies, these metrics
that you can compute rapidly
are good proxies.
Specifically here
during the time
when we had peak
tiger spawning period,
you can see that these
increases in number of calls
match quite nicely
with increases
with our acoustic level,
so we're definitely
do a good job measuring
tiger grouper presence.
But so in addition, while
we had all these calls, what
I didn't mention right
away is that we didn't just
have one recorder either.
We had multiple recorders.
We had up to four
to five recorders
simultaneously
collecting this data
in an array that was about
50 meter by 50 meter large.
And so what you can
do when you have
that kind of a
setup is if you hear
the same sound of
multiple instruments,
you can use the
difference in the time
of the arrival of that same
signal to multiple locations
to localize where the sound
is actually coming from.
And so the process
then consists basically
of finding the
sound of interest,
doing some acoustic processing
where you filter it,
you rectify the
signal, and then you
do cross-correlation between
the two pairs of instruments.
And you look for the
time delay and the peak
of that cross-correlation.
And that gives you
the time delay.
And you'll notice here,
this is time in seconds.
So our peak is just slightly
off or off from zero.
So this is a small array.
We're looking at very,
very small time differences
because we are localizing
in a very small time scale.
But what you get once you have
this time delay with any two
instruments, what that gives
you is this hyperbolic solution.
So it's a hyperbola along which
that sound may have occurred.
And then if you
have multiple pairs,
you get multiple
hyperbole, and where
they cross that is where
your sound is occurring.
So what Casey's is in
the process of doing then
is overlaying the locations
of all these different sounds
that we can localize
on a map that was
collected of habitat quality.
So what I'm showing you
here, the black triangles
are the instrument
recorder locations.
And then the circles
of different colors
are calls of different species.
There are different call
types for different species.
All the blue ones are the
Nassau and tiger calls.
The red, there's a couple
of them, are the Red hind.
There's also some
black grouper and some
that we haven't identified
the species yet.
And so you see there is
quite a few calls that
have occurred here.
And then underneath it, this
is the bottom, the reef.
And the lighter areas
are sandy patches
and then these darker parts are
coral or other hard structure.
So what we're in
the process now,
just kind of qualitatively
looking at this,
it appears of these
intersections or kind
of borderline between sand
and rough reef structure maybe
really important habitat.
We're in the process of
actually quantifying those call
localizations and seeing
what kind of habitat
different calling occurs on.
So to sum up, I hope
I've convince you
that acoustics can be
a really powerful tool
to help us learn more about the
biology, distribution, ecology
of a variety of marine animals.
In particular though,
what we're finding is
it's going to be very
important to understand
the context of these
different calls
to really go further in bringing
that context into management
perspective understanding
better where and when
and why the different
animals are occurring.
And then I think what's
going to be important also
is to continue, there's
been a lot of advances
on the hardware
side and of things.
But I think the future
advances are really
coming in our ability
to process this data
and interpret this data.
And I think using
qualitative tools
and combining techniques
of different fields
is going to be crucial to that.
So I think that's the
next exciting thing.
So with that, I want to
acknowledge the funding
agencies and all the
collaborators and students
and I thank you
for your attention.
[APPLAUSE]
-So, if I could get
you to sit up here
and we can take questions
from the audience.
And if you don't have them,
I have some questions myself.
But, yeah.
You should take the microphone.
-I have a question
for each speaker.
Is that OK?
-Yeah.
-So first, Rachel,
I was just wondering
you're advocating and
planning for transitioning
from hard shoreline protection
to living coastline.
How are you factoring
in the anticipated rise
in ocean level?
-Yeah, so it will
depend on where
you're considering
doing living shorelines
versus hard shorelines.
And I will say at first, I think
we'll have a hybrid approach
everywhere.
So places like New
York City or Miami
where you have a lot
of hard infrastructure,
you're going to need some
engineering structures
like floodgates.
You're going to need
seawalls in some places.
And the idea is to kind of
integrate the living components
in with the hard infrastructure
for these really heavily
urbanized areas that are going
to see a lot of sea level rise,
like Miami.
In some areas where we
expect in the next 100 years
there to be enough for
the area to be underwater,
we're essentially trying to plan
for that retreat, in the sense
that a lot of these
living designs
put the hard structure
seaward of the habitat
they're trying to protect,
so that as you the sea
level rises, those
habitats, those marshes,
could actually migrate
landward without having
a hard structure behind them.
So that's one way that the
living shoreline approach,
particularly with the off
shore kind of protection
is factoring in sea
level, is that assuming
that those habitats
can migrate like they
would if you didn't
have any development.
But again that's also assuming
that the rates of sea level
don't increase too rapidly.
So we still have-- there's a
lot of new research right now
on using dredge material to
actually deposit sediment
onto marshes like in
the Gulf Coast's that
are sediment starved
and are actually sinking
as sea level is rising
to help them keep up
and be able to migrate.
So I think we're
going to need a lot
of different-- both engineering
and ecological techniques.
And it's going to be
very region specific.
So a it's complicated.
-The other question I had is
a question I've always had
and I never had a
chance to ask it before,
which is, what exactly
is it about sonar that
makes it deleterious to
whales and other sea life?
How specifically,
physiologically
does it impact the whale?
-So there's several
different types of sonar.
There is the low frequency
sonar that can be anywhere.
It's really usually
below the kilohertz.
And the mid frequency
active sonar
is the one that's been
most implicated recently
in the last 16, 20
years in stranding
events for [? Adonisees ?] but
really a variety of species.
And it's an interesting
question because the frequencies
at which those
sonars are occurring
are not necessarily
the same frequencies
at which the animals are
producing sound, and therefore
would it be reasonable to
assume that their hearing is
most sensitive.
But in the cases
where we have seen
impact is basically in
animals that have stranded
and they've had various
internal damage in air cavities
and structures of that nature.
So there is presumably some
resonance in the air cavities
and soft tissues
resulting from the sonar.
But I mean it's a lot more
complicated I think than just
direct physiological
impact often,
because we certainly
know there's a variety
of bathometric and other
constrains that lead to some
of these events, leading to
standings and others that
don't.
So it's a complex answer.
I'm not sure that I answered
your question satisfactorily.
-These changes that you see in
the dead whales, [INAUDIBLE]
-The which?
I'm missing--
-They die [INAUDIBLE]
They die on the beach.
-Right.
But so sometimes,
often they'll strand
or they come on the
beach because they're
disoriented or
otherwise under stress
and are trying to
escape whatever,
move away from whatever source
is causing them distress.
So they may die from
the internal injuries,
but that's not always the case.
Sometimes they'll just die
from the process of stranding,
where they don't want to
be in the environment that
is causing them stress.
-Question in the back.
-Yes, Dr. Gittman.
This is a question about
denial of sea level rise.
And I wonder what the
scientific community
is going to do about this.
I can hear all of the
Band-Aid approaches
to dealing with
this, but my sense
is that scientists
are trying to be
as conservative and cautious as
they can be about the sea level
rise, but it's rising.
So you have at least from
the Carolinas north, just
affecting the East
Coast, what will
be a disaster down the
line, and band-aids
aren't going to fix it.
And a couple of
things there I believe
it was the North
Carolina government that
is in a state of
denial from hell
to put it gently, much
like climate change denial.
So they wouldn't
allow, what was it,
a law or regulation
to go through.
And I'm sure there
are one of many.
I think of Miami, all
the time like this.
But I can see where this is
going to be a real problem.
What's your take on that, if
you want to make it public?
But my real question is what
is the science community
going to do because they've
got to educate people?
-It is a very complicated issue.
We are in a very polarized
political society right now.
And I think it's gotten even
more polarized even since I
started graduate school.
When I started in
North Carolina,
it was pre the passing of
the ban on sea level rise.
And I was actually working
with the Coastal Resources
Commission and with the
Division of Coastal Management
and they were fairly proactive.
They had a science
panel that had
developed different
trajectories for sea level rise.
And they were basing their
mucosal management policies
on these different trajectories.
And North Carolina in the '70s
was actually very progressive
and they banned all shoreline
hardening on open coasts.
So if you were in
North Carolina you
don't see sea walls
on any of the beaches.
You'll see an occasional
jetty or groin
that the Army Corps built
in maybe the '40s or '50s
at major inlets,
but you don't have
hardening like you see in
other parts of the country.
And then when I was
in graduate school,
we had a change in
the political arena,
and they essentially turned
over the entire Department
of Natural Resources.
They dismantled
the science panel.
And they passed a law,
largely driven by developers,
who wanted to be able to
develop in high risk areas,
because it would in the short
term make them a lot of money.
They said, we don't
want you to make
any new law about
coastal management
based on any projection
on future sea level
rise it has to be based on
historic rates of sea level
rise, which no climate
scientists would agree
is in any way reasonable.
Because the idea is that the
sea level rise is accelerating.
But that was the
law they passed.
And so they since have
overturned our ban
on shoreline
hardening and are now
allowing terminal groins,
which are basically
put in place where
you have developers
wanting to build in extremely
dynamic, unstable inlet areas.
And they want to
have these groins put
in place to protect their high
risk, high dollar developments.
So, yeah, North Carolina
has gone kind of backwards
since I have lived there.
But the scientific
community is basically
trying to do a
multifaceted approach.
So we obviously, in a lot
of areas, are saying retreat
is going to be the only
option in the long term.
I mean you're going
to have to move away.
And we're a disaster
driven society.
So it will likely take events
like Sandy, like Katrina,
where whole communities
are going to get wiped out,
and then we're going to
choose to not rebuild.
And that's a very sad
way of looking at it.
But I think it's the
most likely scenario,
because everything we've seen
in terms of coastal management
changes has been reactionary.
We are seeing more funding
post-Sandy I think,
for resilience efforts.
Some of the major cities
like New York, Miami,
are starting to think about ways
they can plan for the future.
So New York has adopted
like a long term
plan for how they're
going to deal
with sea level
rise that includes
gray and green infrastructure.
There's a design
in place right now
that will actually let part
of the downtown area flood
naturally and then just recede
by including kind of vegetation
and a series of
floodgates, and you
know it'll be a combined effort
of engineering and ecology.
So I think we just
try to advocate
for many different solutions
in many different phases
of this process.
I think if you just
preach retreat,
you will only reach a small
portion of the population.
So the surveys I showed in the
talk were to the 850 responses,
we asked the question,
how much do you
think sea level is going
to rise and how do you
think it will
affect your property
and what are you going to do?
And most people said, I
mean the range in sea level
went from zero to 100 feet.
I mean people have no
idea how much sea level
is going to rise.
And so that's one issue is
the education component.
Two, even if they said
it was going to rise,
I got responses of
mostly, well, it's
not going affect me it's going
to affect the next generation.
Because a lot of people that
live on the waterfront in North
Carolina are retirees.
You know, this is where they've
retired and they're like,
well, you know, my grandkids
will deal with that.
And then the third part of what
are they going to do about it?
Overwhelmingly, most
people said nothing.
And most people said they
were willing to pay over
100% increase in their insurance
even with sea level rise,
so they're not willing
to move either.
They're going to
pay the insurance.
And so one change we may see
is that the insurance companies
are starting to pull out.
So in the Outer Banks
in North Carolina,
they won't insure whole
stretches of shoreline.
You can't rebuild based
on insurance anymore.
You have to be willing to build
your house with no insurance.
People still do it.
But it's at least moving
in that direction.
So people respond to
monetary incentives I
think more than anything else.
And so, once we
show that it's going
to cost more than
it's worth, I think
we'll start to see more retreat.
-Thank you.
-Until 2012, I lived on a
barrier reef, Singer Island
in Florida, off West Palm.
And I saw all this
and all the variations
that you've described of
solutions for the shore.
So when I would talk to people,
you have public access legally
to the ocean in Florida,
the Atlantic coast.
So I say, well, we
really shouldn't
be building-- it should
be like five miles inland.
And of course
that's not popular.
I said, OK, well,
how about three.
You know, that's
not popular either.
So I understand that money
is the loudest talker
and has the most
seats at the table.
But going back to
education, I think
the only big piece that
will ever change anything
is the education of the very
youngest people now alive,
our children to understand
what will happen
and that they're going to take
on the mantle of stewardship.
And when they've lived
with that for 20 years,
they might be willing
to change and make
decisions that will be good.
But you won't find
people now to be
willing to make those changes.
So you have to work at
all those levels at once
in order to hope that
in a quarter century
there might be real progress.
-I completely agree.
One thing we are
doing-- so education
is a huge component of
the work that we do.
And we have like
demonstration projects,
and you know I've done several
field trips out to a living
shoreline.
I showed a picture of the
oyster reef living shoreline
that we constructed in 2012.
And we bring-- this is part
of an estaurine research.
So we bring children
out, we teach them
about the living shoreline.
But we're also still invested
in educating adults too.
One of the big things
in North Carolina
is to initiate-- this kind of
an under the radar Initiative
that's mostly funded through
donations and through NGOs
and not obviously through
our legislature right now,
but is to start a
green engineering
or like living
shoreline certification
program for marine contractors
and engineering firms.
And that's mainly because
your average homeowner
will buy waterfront
property, see that's eroding,
and not know what
to do about it.
And they'll just look up,
they'll go into Google
and find a coastal engineering
firm or a contractor,
call them and say, my shoreline
is eroding, what do I do?
And your average
contractor has been putting
in bulkheads for three decades.
And they say, well,
this is what you need.
You need a bulkhead.
And they say that because that's
what they know how to build
and that's what's going
to cost the most money.
And it also actually costs
the most maintenance,
but they're not going
to tell them that.
And so now I've participated
in two training sessions
for real estate developers,
landscape architects, and then
engineering and
contracting firms
on how to build
living shorelines
and how it could
potentially make them money.
Because they could go back
and help maintain the plants.
They can basically get free
advertising through the state,
because they'll have
the certification.
So there are ways
that we're trying
to reach some of
the key players,
but it's a slow process.
Again, people are
resistant to change.
But I'm still optimistic.
OK, we can take a
break in a second.
But I have the opportunity
to ask one question.
I wanted to ask Anna.
So I will confess to be being
something of a language maven.
I'm not an expert
in linguistics,
but I'm always interested
in languages and how they
evolve and change in humans.
And what struck me was, when
you were talking about the whale
populations, I
was just wondering
in the back of my mind,
do they learn their songs?
And is there an evolution
over time and location
the same way you would see
different language populations
in humans on Earth?
Does that sound right?
-Yes, so there are several
examples now that we've seen.
In humpback whales, songs change
over time and they evolve.
And we have seen now
that in some there
is an example off
of Australia where
there was a new animal that came
to the East Coast of Australia,
singing the Western
Australia song.
And within two
seasons, everybody
adopted the new songs.
Clearly it was better.
But then there's
also this gradual--
-The hip, new whales
the cool new whale.
-Exactly, and also
humpback song is really
the one that's been most
looked at in studies.
We know there a kind of a
cultural transmission of song
across the Pacific from
the West to the East,
where it's been progressively
changing and moving its way.
But recently,
actually some of the
work that I'm doing
with colleagues,
we're finding that fin
whales, which they actually
have very similar pattern of
the sound that they produce.
It's just this very
short, down sweep,
but the pattern in
which they produce them,
they're very, very
regularly repeated.
It's almost like a metronome.
And what we have found
is that in some places,
they'll have these songs change
or the pattern of the intervals
changes across the year, where
it starts relatively fast,
and then gradually gets slower
and slower across the mating
season.
And so, all the fin whales
across the North Pacific
do the same thing,
the same pattern.
They start at the same rate
and then they all together
get slower and slower.
And then in Southern
California just recently,
we've seen that they've
actually changed their song.
And now it's a completely
different pattern
that just slowly,
gradually there's
no longer the seasonal
cycle, but over time it's
getting slower and slower.
So there clearly is some
transmission and exchange
between these
different populations,
but we don't really know a
whole lot about how that works.
-Fascinating.
OK, so let's thank
our speakers again.
[APPLAUSE]